I need to jump to Mexico because after
that country's most notorious drug lord
el chapo shorty escaped a high-security
prison by a makeshift tunnel this
weekend many questions are being raised
about why he wasn't extradited to the
United States bloomberg's Victor
Michelle is in Mexico City he has
covered the drug war and the nation's
problematic prison system Victor what
explanation does the president Enrique
Pena Nieto have to offer for the fact
that El Chapo escaped and furthermore
that his decision not to have him
extradited to the United States now
proved has proven to be so mistaken good
morning yet this is a hugely
embarrassing development for president
Pena Nieto he came into office three
years ago with a promise with the
pretense that his government would
implement better security strategies a
more intelligent way to fight the drug
cartels and now we have this situation a
year ago that then attorney-general
isuzu do qadam said that he would gladly
extradited chapo guzman to the United
States only after he served a 400 year
prison sentence here in Mexico obviously
that wasn't going to happen one of the
main theories that is going around here
in Mexico is that the Mexican government
didn't want to x-ray at El Chapo to the
United States because he would give a
lot of embarrassing information to the
American officials about mexican
officials Mexican government figures
that have been bought off in the past
years so 18 people and perhaps more have
been taken into questioning prison
employees do you have any word on what
they've been saying or any of them
talking yeah at this point they're being
questioned by us trained interrogators
they are part of the attorney general's
office they're going to be interrogated
for the next couple of days no
information has been given about what
they are saying but we have confirmation
that at this point several high-ranking
officials high-ranking oppression of
prison officials have been fired and are
being questioned also because there is a
presumption that there was cooperation
from inside the prison well and they're
all
he had a cooperation there's no way that
a chapel could have Tony oh god himself
tunnel that himself and furthermore had
a motorcycle track waiting upon his
arrival Victor we thank you very much
for the update on the escape of El Chapo
and what the Mexican government is doing
about it Victor Michelle in Mexico City